megan vite un véritable conte de fées à
11 ans seulement
cet artiste originaire de stoneham a
vendu 88 de ses peintures très longtemps
donc ces délais sont réfléchis donc
procès on est encore cette année c'est
ce que je pense à comment je vais le
faire avant son histoire est intrigante
dès l'âge de 7 ans megan suit des cours
puis rapidement son talent attire
l'attention des amateurs d'art
visiblement elle aime l'art abstrait
c'est pas un ours n'ont peut être s'y
voit quoi
ouah joie y voit un chien mais ça
ressemble alors le succès est tel que
megan un agent aux états unis et ses
toiles s'envole parfois pour plus de
1000 $ je pense que ces sondages qui est
créée c'est l'idée de créer comme ça
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on voit
régulièrement ou du tout carrément le
ici au québec ou même au canada en
allemagne un jeune peintre de 6 ans a
déjà défrayé les manchettes
nous avons fait découvrir l'oeuvre de
megan fortin au réputé galeriste luc
charbonneau faudrait que les adore
beaucoup de plaisir
et voici ce qu'ils avaient à nous dire
moi je pense que
si quelqu'un aime les arts vivants
encourager la jeune fille jeu rien de
mauvais là d'un temps qu'il ne fait pas
pour pour le but spéculatif
investissement plus pour une vue humain
le ferai plus pour cette raison le
syndicat et artistique c'est comme un
bon chanteur
on peut avoir un talent brut mais il
faut développer l'outil et puis il faut
être capable de se renouveler
megan est sur une lancée et elle est
bien décidée à faire une carrière en art
7 autant donc ici oui j'ai depuis mai
radio canada montréal